qui est pour qui est contre la science
est levée
la séance est levée
bonjour je suis Lisa belluco député
écologiste de la Vienne alors ici on
n'est pas sur ma circonscription on est
juste à côté mais si je suis ici c'est
pour vous montrer ces méga bassines donc
c'est ce qu'on voit derrière moi ce sont
des réserves de substitution qui servent
à stocker de l'eau pour l'agriculture et
pour l'irrigation pour l'utiliser en été
quand il y a des sécheresses et c'est
vraiment ce que je ne veux pas voir ce
développer dans mon département
des millions de mètres cubes d'eau dans
lesquels les agriculteurs puisent pour
arroser leur culture
principalement du maïs très gourmand en
eau
dans la Vienne un protocole vient
d'autoriser la création de 30 nouvelles
réserves comme celle-ci
donc une partie sur la circonscription
de l'isabet Ducau
elle permettront de prélever en hiver
près de 9 millions de mètres cubes dans
les nappes phréatiques une hérésie pour
la députée écologiste
on a l'idée que nos nappes phréatiques
sont trop remplies en hiver et du coup
on veut pomper dans les nappes
phréatiques pour remplir ses bassines
pour pouvoir utiliser l'eau l'été et
pour
moins consommer d'eau d'été ou pouvoir
arroser même s'il y a une sécheresse là
où ça marche pas c'est que nos nappes
phréatiques ne sont pas en surplus
l'hiver pour l'instant on ne peut pas
remplir les bassines et c'est ce qui
risque de se reproduire donc moi je
pense que mon rôle c'est vraiment de
d'en parler de poser des questions aux
ministres de mettre à l'agenda du
gouvernement ce sujet des mégavassines
qui qui n'était pas un sujet jusqu'à
maintenant
la bataille de l'eau a déjà commencé
dans le département
les sécheresses s'intensifient et les
cours d'eau sont plus bas que jamais
qui se reproduisaient la moitié des
rivières de la Vienne est quasiment à
sec c'est le cas de la palu au nord de
Poitiers on est en train de regarder le
désastre
d'habitude ici on devrait avoir 4 à 5
mètres d'eau mais aujourd'hui il y a
plus rien cette rivière fait 30 km elle
est complètement séchée
[Musique]
vous voyez donc
cette même rivière avec l'eau qui
devrait y avoir normalement dedans et ça
avait été photographié ça le 7 septembre
2013 et vous voyez ce qu'on a vu cet été
voilà nos belles troué voilà nos
poissons
voilà des verrons et voilà le résultat
on a chiffré le préjudice écologique
rien qu'en mortalité de poisson on est à
plus de 5 millions d'euros
ok on va aller voir de plus près
les trucs fario ont totalement disparu
de la Palud
trop de dérogations trop de pompage dans
les eaux la rivière n'a pas résisté
oui
c'est pas acceptable de voir de voir il
y a plus d'eau normalement l'eau devrait
arriver ici il y a plus rien
donc voilà
complètement sec la palure la zone
certainement la plus influencée par les
prélèvements agricoles c'est là qu'on va
rencontrer le plus d'irrigation en plein
été parce que dans ce secteur c'est des
grandes cultures c'est des grandes
cultures souvent des très grosses
propriétés
céréalières on a plus d'eau sur
certaines années qui a envoyé sur les
cultures que d'eau qui coule dans la
rivière pour vous montrer l'ampleur du
déséquilibre au niveau de l'usage de la
ressource sur ce bassin versant là on
plus d'eau à irriguer qu'à que que la
rivière
et selon eux les cinq méga bassines en
projet dans le secteur n'arrangeront pas
la situation
au pied de la palu à sec les abeilles
ducaux a donc trouvé un allié inattendu
c'est vrai que on se connaissait pas
avant avant de se rencontrer sur la la
situation des réserves de substitution
et on n'est pas des alliés naturels ce
qui est idiot parce qu'effectivement les
meilleurs connaisseurs des milieux
aquatiques ce sont ce sont les pêcheurs
aujourd'hui en face les irrégants ils
sont très forts et ils ont vraiment
l'oreille du préfet mais on voit que les
pêcheurs aussi
alors que les associations
environnementales sur des questions
comme ça on dit bon bah c'est les écolos
c'est bon quoi quand il y a la
fédération de pêche qui dit mais moi non
plus je suis pas tout à fait d'accord
déjà ça permet de de jouer un peu à
Omega avec les face aux irrigants
je pense qu'on est des lanceurs d'alerte
parce que lorsqu'il y a de l'eau dans
les rivières il y a de l'eau potable
aussi et si on n'a pas de recharge
hivernale on va boire je sais pas quoi
l'année prochaine
comme les pêcheurs la députée écologiste
a refusé de signer le protocole d'accord
des 30 réserves du bassin du Clain
mais elle va devoir composer avec les
agriculteurs irrigants de son
département
donc là donc ici on est sur une partie
de l'exploitation sur un des îlots
principaux qui lui est irrigué donc sur
la gauche vous savez une parcelle de blé
qui était envahissent l'année dernière
on est dans les dans les rotations et
sur l'autre partie qui est aujourd'hui
en herbe là on est avec des couverts
végétaux qui vont normalement permettre
de porter des parcelles de maïs si bien
sûr nous avons l'eau nécessaire à son
implantation
Olivier pin maraîcher et producteur de
maïs semences est aussi le président des
irrigans de la Vienne
comme beaucoup il dispose de dérogations
préfectorales de prélèvement d'eau pour
irriguer ses champs moi l'eau vient
directement de la rivière je suis un des
derniers préleveurs rivières historiques
dans le secteur
mais aujourd'hui c'est insuffisant et il
craint de ne plus pouvoir honorer ses
contrats de vente avec sa coopérative
on continue pour le moment avoir ces
contrats mais si demain de toute façon
on n'a pas une ressource qui est validée
stockée nous n'aurons plus ces contrats
son seul espoir une retenue d'eau à
laquelle il sera bientôt raccordé
votre réserve de substitution elle sera
sur cette parcelle
les plans aujourd'hui qu'on a conçus
sont sur cette parcelle là effectivement
qui fait entre 6 7 hectares
208 000 mètres cubes d'eau partagée
entre 4 agriculteurs aux alentours
l'équivalent de 55 piscines olympiques
le protocole prévoit de raccorder 153
exploitations
raccordement en partie financé par
l'État alors qu'il y a 2000 agriculteurs
sur le bassin les abélucos dénoncent
cette appropriation de l'eau
ça concerne très très peu de très très
peu d'agriculteurs mais ça concerne des
agriculteurs sur des secteurs qui sont
hyper vulnérables c'est un accaparement
le mot est dur mais c'est un accaparent
de l'eau pour quelques-uns au début
après j'entends qu'on puisse connecter
d'autres personnes j'entends que ça
puisse être
étendu mais le projet aujourd'hui c'est
pas ça je reproche
que le la logique soit faite à partir
des besoins et pas à partir des de l'eau
disponibles et j'ai juste peur qui est
pas assez d'eau et vous serez en
diffuserez les premières en pâtir en
fait mais toute façon si on a pas d'eau
on sera plus là je dis pas que retenir
l'eau c'est une mauvaise idée je dis que
à cette échelle et avec ses volumes ça
me semble une mauvaise idée parce que
on est dans une phase de changement
climatique et que on risque de
on sait qu'on aura moins d'eau
le partage équitable de l'eau la députée
en est convaincu ne pourra se faire
qu'avec une agriculture moins gourmande
plus raisonnée c'est aussi le combat de
la Confédération paysanne bonjour
le syndicat agricole a convié les quatre
députés du département
seul Lisa belluco et Pascal le camp ont
accepté lui est député MoDem et il
défend les réserves d'eau on va aller
faire une visite allez Tony emmène-nous
sur les terres de cet éleveur d'agneau
en herbe sans irrigation le débat entre
pro et antibacine s'engagent rapidement
on a deux positions qui pourraient
s'entendre je suis convaincue qu'à la
fin de cette rencontre il aura un autre
avis sur la situation
mais moi je parle à tout le monde
et je connais le dossier les réserves
c'est pour combien de mètres millions de
mètres cubes
ces exploitants ont fait le choix d'une
agriculture moins intensive plus
respectueuse des sols selon eux
auprès des parlementaires ils cherchent
un appui pour une meilleure utilisation
de l'eau c'est ça c'est pour remplir le
ricard les bâtiments en fait
[Musique]
l'irrigation pour nous il y a certaines
productions qui doivent être priorisées
le maraîchage laboriculture voir
l'élevage voire la production de
semences mais faire débats pour produire
du maïs qui va aller soit à La Palisse
pour être exporter soit dans un
méthaniseur pour produire du gaz ou de
l'électricité ça nous pose fortement
problème il faut faire un travail
agronomique sur l'amélioration des sols
et non de stockage de l'autre plus
directement dans les sols et faire
d'autres cultures et surtout pas du maïs
je sais pas je suis pas technicien mais
on voit bien qu'il y a sans doute une
solution c'est ce qui semble le plus
d'eau au mois d'août quand tu en as plus
du tout même s'il y en a moins
aujourd'hui il demande de l'eau à
travers des bassines on leur dit pas de
problème on va vous on va vous les
financer je suis en vente de cet accès à
l'eau les irrigans s'engagent à
replanter des haies préserver les
milieux aquatiques et diminuer de moitié
l'utilisation des pesticides
l'état promet de contrôler mais ce ne
sera pas si simple à la session vendredi
dernier un agriculteur qui a dit mais
moi les contreparties je les suivrai pas
je les respecterai pas
publique
face au Méga bassine ce sont en réalité
deux mondes agricoles qui s'affrontent
et qui cherchent des
compromisateurs et des législateurs le
préfet que ça pue aussi sur les
parlementaires pour avoir des retours de
terrain il s'appuie aussi sur les élus
locaux enfin sur tout un tas de
personnes si on a des parlementaires qui
pensent pas tous pareils ça change aussi
la configuration du débat je pense ça
alimente le débat
pour défendre sa cause la députée n'a
pas hésité à se joindre à un
rassemblement interdit
c'était fin octobre sur le chantier de
la méga bassine de sainte Soline dans le
département voisin les abusaux étaient
dans le cortège des élus au première
loge face aux gendarmes lorsque la
manifestation d'opposants a tourné court
[Musique]
Lisa bellucco a depuis dénoncé les coups
des gendarmes et porter plainte pour
violence
quand il y a une élue qui se fait
frapper par des gendarmes on peut aussi
imaginer que le ministre de l'Intérieur
lui envoie un petit mot et la seule
ministre de l'Intérieur il dit que je
suis une terroriste donc je sais pas
dans quel monde on est entré mais on est
en train dans un monde qui qui va pas
bien enfin ça va pas de c'est pas
possible de faire ça moi je crois que là
si ça continue comme ça on est entré
dans une gare de lot on est entré le
gouvernement ce gouvernement a déclenché
une guerre de l'eau dans son département
les abbé Ducau va devoir affronter trois
députés de la majorité favorables au
projet pour elle la guerre de l'eau ne
fait que commencer
[Musique]